hey everybody its Jesse and I hope you
all had a great weekend if anybody did
anything awesome let me know in the live
chat today I'm going to do something
that for some of you is going to seem
really simple but for others this may be
the first time you've actually seen this
done and I've gotten a pull request from
one of you that's that's been watching
the streams and I checked it out Friday
afternoon I I pulled it down to my
machine as a separate branch and checked
it out and I only found one thing that
was different and it was simply because
I messed something up input and
basically it caused a class not to be
applied to an element and it looked good
like that and then when the person who
submitted the pull request fixed it it
changed the appearance and it actually
changed it to what it should have been
based on the classes that were there but
I actually don't like it like that so
that's the only thing that I'm really
going to change for this everything else
is awesome so I'm going to take you
through just you know quickly a quick
scan of okay here's here's what's
changed so you can see like where to go
to look at if somebody submits a pull
request for your project kind of go
through the steps of how you would
evaluate that and then what you would do
to merge it into your your branch also I
had some requests for me to use an grok
I don't know how it's ng or okay I'm
just going to say n grok if that's not
how you pronounce it then let me know in
the live chat but this is going to let
you all go to the development version of
the site
so instead of waiting to see on the
screen what I change and you only being
able to see what I'm showing on my
screen you can look at the site as it's
being developed on my local machine so
I'm this site's being served on port
3000 for the dev site so I'm just going
to start this and now let me blow this
up a little bit so if you want to go to
I'm going to paste this in the
description okay so in the live chat
I've just pasted in the the URL is just
talking about if you go there you'll be
able to see the site so it's not going
to be a Wow look at that it looks like
some people were going there so I can
see all the requests here it's not going
to be that useful today since you know
we're just merging your pool requests so
we're not making a lot of like little
changes that we want to check out but
it'll definitely useful in the future
I'm going to check the live chat really
quickly before we get started because
looks like some people were saying hi
hey everybody alright Thor is so he's
finally on time so Thor is frequently
watches the live show but always drops
in a little bit later so awesome that
you're here a long time Sebastian says
check material UI comm material design
with react on it while browsing yeah I
am I've been [ __ ] I've actually been
checking it out actually you have open
on one of my other screens right now a
material design react it's not a
framework I was looking at react MD but
I've also seen material UI as well I
actually was going to go with material I
once there was like one component that
they did
have built yet that I needed to use and
I didn't feel like building it myself at
the time so but I definitely want to
check that out I think that would be
better right now I'm using materialized
I'm trying to make it work in in react
my goal was to kind of translate
everything materialized does and to
react components but maybe it would just
be a lot easier to use one of these
other react component libraries and they
use material design and then just
contribute to those for the things that
that are missing that I use seem to live
load at the site it looks like yeah
we're getting a lot of requests so is it
is it working is is the the dev site
thing working
there's are too many too many people
connecting too many I'll just say
alright let me show you what is fit so
too many connections the rate limit
policy of 20 connections per minute Wow
143 connections last 60 seconds okay so
off to think of something else
I don't know what the paid plan for an
Groth is off to check that out after
stream if it's not a lot of money then
maybe I'll get it I just have no idea
how much it how much it is but yeah this
isn't going to work right now so sorry
about that but I mean for today it's I
guess I'll just shut this down since
it's already shutting down on its own so
yeah it's not gonna be a big deal today
but maybe I'll look it up and see either
if there's an alternative that lets make
more connections or if I could just pay
for for the paid version of an grogg so
thanks to everybody that suggested that
it is really cool I hopefully we can get
it working with this volume
hmm Thor says it's $5 for 60 requests
per minute which is still not enough
because we had 143 connections in a
minute
so $12 for 120 so it's getting closer
my interest is DDoS successfully uh yes
as that those but yeah you guys just
definitely DDoS my deaf site all right
so let's get started um I have a meeting
at 3:00 so if you notice the pattern I
have a meeting at 3 o'clock every Monday
so I wanted to keep this short which is
part of the reason why I picked this
topic to do right now because I don't
think it'll take that long the other
part of the reason is because if you
never really did this before this might
be good to see I know I always get
nervous when I'm doing something you
know - my codebase bringing something in
like will I mess it up now obviously
since I'm using git I shouldn't be that
nervous I can always just roll it back
to previous commit but it's still it's
kind of nice to see something
demonstrated and especially since I'll
demonstrate it live maybe I'll make a
mistake and that's even better because
then you'll know not to do what I did I
do really feel that way I think it's it
ends up being better for it for you most
of the time if I mess things up because
then I don't you learn you learn more
because not only we usually fix it
eventually so you know what to do but
you also learn what not to do or how to
get out of it once you mess it up so
basically just to recap the steps that
I've already taken I just followed these
is it these ones yeah I followed these
instructions right super easy so this is
right on github follow these
instructions to basically do this just
make another branch that's this this fix
okay so I really just kind of
[Music]
I'll show you what the request was so
this is the pull request so thanks to
the Vinay pull pal I'm not sure how to
pronounce that exactly if you're
watching oh yeah there you are president
brevity realize looking up that
okay so Vinay is in the last chat right
now so thank you very much for this
request I checked it out and it's
awesome and I'll show you guys a little
bit about what was changed just to show
you how great this is so anyway this is
the this is what you'll see if somebody
does a pull request and like I said if
if this is like old news to you and easy
stuff then sorry but consider sticking
around and maybe giving some tips to
everybody that's that's in the live chat
so I'm going to show you the the files
that have changed and this is kind of
the important part I think to me just to
check things out and understand what's
going on I love looking at these the
last of that in to pull requests so far
and I've learned so much from both of
them by being able to compare what I did
with what what they did in the pull
request and seeing how I can improve my
own code in the future so we could see
here so we have now this component file
this head is which we actually some
people asked about I don't remember who
it was in the live chat but I had at
least one person maybe more asked about
moving all of this head stuff into its
own component and I remember I had said
I think that would be a good good to do
I'm just not sure how I would do it yet
and I just never got around to actually
trying to figure out how to do it as you
know it was it kind of a tight schedule
so a lot of things that I thought were
great ideas just got kind of pushed
pushed back and not done so there's also
this so here's one new component
completely new and that's all the stuff
we had in the head and we needed
everything in the head can basically be
the same for every page except we needed
this title tag and we needed the meta
description right so now we can actually
pass that in okay the title in the
description so that's that's awesome
like that
the part that was really giving me a bit
of trouble was I need passivating but
also there was some error that I was
getting when I tried to do this and so I
just kind of gave up on it when I first
tried and when I finally kind of
realized how I could have fixed the
error
I was already moved on to something else
and I just never attempted it again so
the next component is layout j/s so this
is totally new and this does what you
would think it does this is the layout
for the page so we had a lot of
repetitious code we never want to do
that right we always want to stay dry
right
do not repeat okay that's the that's the
principle right so we don't want to
repeat all this so you can see
especially like this we're bringing in
that head that was just created here
bringing that in here because we need
that for every page we also we had this
div for every page we always have a
footer we always import these scripts at
the bottom here so all this stuff is now
taken out and put into its own component
it makes all the rest of the components
a little bit cleaner and we don't repeat
ourselves so that's awesome
great idea also the Google Analytics
code is initialized here as well so we
don't initialize it everywhere and these
changes are all spread out over a bunch
of commits and each commit has its own
message to kind of explain it to so I
mean that's that's all there and to get
the github repo and there's a link to
that in the description so you can check
it on your own and kind of go more in
depth if you want to try to understand
some of this this is what I was talking
about at the beginning which actually
changed how things are displayed I'll
show you in a second so we had this
class card action which if you see
obviously this doesn't work because it
needs to be class name card action so
when I first did this I didn't even
catch this because it didn't throw an
error and it looks good I liked how it
looked so I never even thought twice
about it but then when this class name
was at and it's actually card action it
actually changed the display how this
now I don't like how it's displayed
which is of course you know Vinay is did
this 100% correctly this is how it
should have been done I just should have
not used this class on here so what I'm
going to do is either change how this
looks or just completely take out this
this class and see so not sure how I'm
going to do that yet
let me bring over I thought I had it up
here but I guess I didn't oh I know I
could my um my computer started making
all kinds of noise like it was working
really hard and so I closed a bunch of
my windows so I ended up closing out the
window for this let me open it up again
oops didn't want to do that there we go
okay so this is reflecting the the
completely changed version see see
there's this line here and then there's
more now normally because of the way
materialise does the styles this
shouldn't be inside it should be like on
the outside of this card it shouldn't be
inside this revealed text so that's why
I'm getting like this should have been
all the way across but now there's
padding so I just kind of took an
element and put in a different spot than
the framework was intending which is
fine but I just need to account for that
and I don't want this color so I need to
change that color this was this is
actually the right color normally for
our sites but since this site has a
different color palette than all the
rest of our sites I do need to change
this and I want to take out this line
I'll show you what it looked like before
just in case you haven't seen it see it
just looked like this and after I looked
at this I thought I I would kind of like
to change this I would like to have this
be all capitals and maybe a different
color maybe a red color we'll see so it
was really good did that happen because
I I hadn't even noticed that so I'm glad
and it's going to make me rethink the
look of that anyway also upgraded next
so
that's good I think I'd already upgraded
to the two point four point two so maybe
like probably this was this was three
bows fort when I was still a four point
one and then at some point within the
last week I think I did upgrade to four
point two because there's a security
upgrade that came out so if you're using
next and you're still on like 4.1 or
lower upgrade to at least two point four
point two because that's an important
security update I don't know enough
about it to tell you exactly what the
issue is but I just know that it seems
serious from what I read so also a lot
of changes here see I'm not going to go
through all these because it's pretty
much the same so pages now we've gotten
rid of all that stuff that's been taken
out and put and put into other
components right so now we just have
layout so we've wrapped all of this in
layout all right which is awesome just
so much less less code in general we no
longer need before we initialize Google
Analytics every time now we don't know
we just love the page view and now
instead of having our title and
description here we just pass it as
props into the layout component and then
that gets in turn pass to the head
component all right so that's it pretty
much all of them I'm going to skip down
because these are all just the same
thing happening on every page pretty
much so just cleaning everything up and
it's important if somebody does submit a
pull request to you go through all this
stuff you know because you don't want to
mess up your project you know because
you missed something and larger projects
have like automatic testing that happens
and which is awesome I don't have that
set up I obviously didn't even expect to
have anybody else submitting pull
requests so I didn't even think to set
it up the final thing is now the
analytics
has been split out into its own
component and there's a new folder utils
right so for utilities so now this is in
its own component which is also a great
idea
so all around just making everything so
much cleaner more kind of separated out
and I really like all those changes so
again thank you so much for this and
look look at that change look how much
you know basically all the same things
are happening but with way less in terms
of total lines of code so really great
pool request so now that we've kind of
gone through the pool requests like how
you how you check it out
now we've pulled down using these
instructions we've pulled that down I've
done that beforehand I did that last
week so I'm not going to show how to do
it I mean it's really like what five
five steps literally five steps and it
works so we're going to merge this
branch now into the master branch but
I'm going to do something I was reading
somewhere maybe a stack overflow
somebody said that when they do merges
what the way they do it is first they
merge the so they they merge everything
that's been done and master so like
there's a lot of stuff that's been done
like since this so this is not
necessarily completely up-to-date I
don't know maybe it is more up-to-date
but there's probably some things that
happen that that aren't in here yet so
I'm going to merge master into this
branch right test it on this branch make
sure everything's okay and then merge
this back into the master branch and I
thought that was kind of a nice idea
maybe not always necessary for small
changes but in this case there are a lot
of changes so I'm going to do it like
that and then that way you know we'll be
able to we'll be able to see and if we
mess up this branch you know not really
a big deal not as big of a deal is if I
messed up master I won't even have to
worry about you know reverting to
previous commit because I'll just switch
back to master and everything will be as
it should be so let me let me check the
live chat really quick because I've been
ignoring it for like ten minutes
okay Thor says there's also hub a CLL
CLI by github to simplify fetching the
pull request oh that's awesome off to
check that out so check that out if you
hub github calm so off to check that out
after this and but rebase instead hey
guys please don't use merge towards
saying please don't use merge master but
rebase instead please
andrew says agree with rebase or get
merge rebates I see so many people in
doing it messing up their history get
rebates master on the future branch and
then switch to master and do merge
feature branch okay yeah so let me where
did I put this I had a link and somebody
was talking about that same thing about
messing up their history and there was a
way to work around it and that's what I
used the last time I did this yes a
rebase master into feature then merge
feature in the master right yeah so all
of them I definitely want to do that in
a way that I can keep my history up so I
so I had a meeting right before this too
so I just got here a few minutes before
I started so otherwise I would have had
this up already but let me let me bring
up the instructions that I was going to
use I'll pull them on the screen and
then you all in the live check and let
me know if this is kind of what you were
thinking or if it's or if you have
something totally different in mind
so I gotta remember I would I would
think that that was something that I
would have saved probably in Google keep
so that's where I'm gonna look first
okay and I did find it I did save it
exactly where I thought it would be I
really like Google keep I don't know if
you all use Google key but it's just
really convenient for me I use Google
for a lot of stuff I have an Android
phone so it works out that it syncs up
nicely
I used to use Evernote for that kind of
thing but keep is more simple and I
didn't ever really use the feature all
the features of Evernote okay so here's
the instructions I was going to use and
then to keep track it looks like this is
not what you were talking about because
you guys are talking about rebate or
rebase and this is just merged so I'm
going to look now back at the live chat
- Tate take a look at this on the screen
hopefully let me blow it up a little bit
more to make sure you can see even if
you're on a small screen check this out
for a second see if this is going to
going to do it yeah
okay so andrew says yeah this part down
here this is yeah this is the part that
I use the last time I did it so that
that will get the job done then awesome
thank you
okay so Thor is saying this will work
but prefers rebase could you maybe just
explain why you prefer rebase I think
it'd be cool and I'd like to read it out
so everybody that's watching even later
on could be could know kind of the
difference I mean I'm sure everybody
could look it up but since we're on the
topic already of the video it'd be nice
to to kind of give the alternate way to
do this
this is Andrew saying if you made any
commits and master it's better to rebase
but I'm wondering I'm wondering why is
it better to rebase so I'll let that I
know there's a delay so all um I'll kind
of get on with it here and then I'll
show how to do it and actually I'm gonna
have more things to merge in so it's
possible that we could do I don't know
if we'll have time today but it's
possible we could do do it both ways and
then see just just to demonstrate that
might be useful you know and helpful so
that you all can see you know the
differences figure out what's easier
patrick said or andrew says rebase will
get all new commits from master put on
feature and then apply all new commits
from feature okay
patrick says rebase allows you to clean
up your history m'kay texas rebase
performs automatic
and checks okay
okay cool so then Thor says rebase will
reset your feature branch to the point
it's split from master apply all new
commits from master and then put your
commits from the feature on top that's
cool that sounds good so - to explain
the difference then so if we merge like
this well at first I was going to
actually merge master into the feature
branch make sure everything's working
while I'm on the feature branch then put
it all back into master so if I did that
so if I used rebase basically all the
commits from master would be in the
history first and then all the commits
from the feature branch would come if I
do it this way that I have up on the
screen now then I'm assuming the history
would be different order forces is
different okay so so that's then the
difference the main difference right you
would just have a different history okay
all right cool so if you're if you're
thinking about doing this if you've
never done this before or if you've done
it one way but not the other then
there's a difference in the history so
I'll actually after I do this I will
look at all the commits just to give you
an idea of what history looks like from
this since I've already explained based
on what everybody's saying in the lab
chat I've already explained what it
would look like if you did rebase and
then we'll be able to see and the
terminal what it would look like this
way so okay so Thor Thor is saying you
would have a master - let's split
then feature commits then new commits or
master
we're doing it this way with rebase you
have master and then feature commits so
Thor says he highly prefers the the
second route to just add master and then
all the feature commits after hmm two
solutions okay so like I said I'm going
to go I'll probably do the next branch
with rebase to demonstrate that I'm
going to go with this one first since I
said I was going to go with this one and
I may as well just do it at this point
but that way you'll have a nice idea of
which one which one to go with all right
so for this branch so you can follow
along I mean the I mean the URL was
crazy for that so I don't know I
couldn't find that that there's
instructions on stackoverflow maybe I'll
I'll just post it in the in the live
chat for now and maybe post it in the
description in case you want to see
those commands so
first we're going to do so we are on the
development branch so that's important
so make sure you're on development
branch and I can tell here and actually
I saw somebody I saw asked the question
let me go back so don't miss it because
it it makes sense to answer this
question right now I can't find it now
but I know somebody said something about
okay so uh rowdy I'm not sure it I must
try to pronounce this it's like Road ro
DW 91 so it says how did you fix your
terminal so it looks like that so yeah
my terminal this is not default if you
never used a terminal before this is not
a default look so basically I did this
so long ago that I couldn't tell you
exactly how I did it like step by step
but basically you have like what's
called like a bash profile and it's just
a file if you heard that in the
background that was my alarm to tell me
it's 2:30 so I need to get a move on
this is in your bash profile you can set
the colors for different things and how
things work so that's what I edited but
I did the git and github course on
Udacity so if you go to Udacity comm
they have a ton of free courses they
also have paid certifications you can
get but the git and github course is
totally free in that course one of the
lessons teaches you how to do this I
actually just used the default example
from the lesson I never even changed it
so I'd always intended that I would
customize the colors but I had some
projects that I did and now I'm so used
to these I don't really want to change
them but you can I would recommend that
that course especially if you're new to
this it was really helpful for me they
take you through a lot of test projects
and have you do pool requests and merge
things and really kind of go through
everything that you would normally
use use git and github for so let's
let's do the first step which is get so
anyway you have to be on the feature
branch to start okay so get merge master
wait what it's already up to date no way
sorry up today and actually
all right so I guess this was that maybe
this did have I I assume that this
didn't have all the changes from from
master huh all right let's try it out
I just I do want to check something
quickly oops
Oh where's my okay I didn't want to
check this just really quickly just to
make sure because I was almost positive
that I had react two point four point
three all right so I'm going to check
that and then that when I switch over I
want to check I never change that that's
crazy that's really crazy because I do
remember maybe I just did it for another
site that I was using next with I know I
did it for one of my client sites maybe
I just never did it so earlier in the in
the show I realized now that I said
something that was incorrect I thought
that I had updated next but I didn't and
I don't know what happened if I don't
know I really could have sworn that I
did update next I thought I updated a
two point four point one or point two I
guess I did not all right so anyway
basically what what happens is this this
pull request was actually this pull
request was actually already completely
up-to-date with everything so it was
really almost kind of pointless for me
to do that but if it wasn't completely
up-to-date then that would have actually
been important and so now this is going
to be really easy so we're going to
merge so we're going to get merge so
whenever you do a merge you're always
merging the branch you specify here into
the branch that you're on so I often
forget that and I always look it up just
to be sure
so I mean don't feel bad if you don't
remember that because I almost never
remember that
but we need to get merged and was the
name of that branch fix thought slash
reactor unit if you if you really
haven't use the command line
you're wondering how I make that appear
so quickly when you're on the command
line if you just type in like the first
letter or first two letters of what
you're looking for and then hit tab it
will try to autocomplete and if there's
like two files or two folders that have
this at the beginning it'll just stop
there and so you'll have to type more in
so that it can autocomplete but that's
that'll save you a ton of time that's
that's something I didn't really know at
first I saw people on YouTube Auto
completing stuff and I just wasn't sure
how that was happening but that's how it
happens and it's awesome all right so
let's go ahead and merge great now in
this case there are no conflicts okay
there occasionally you will have a con
conflict no um I forgot to do the step I
told you I was going to do in this case
it didn't matter because um it was
already up to date basically like the
glog let me show you the log okay so you
can see the log and who did these
changes
let's see so these changes are like
actually in the right order you can see
the dates and everything and yeah so
right order now what we had talked about
before and I can't remember I can't
believe I forgot this was using this
instead get merged okay so we talked
about doing this to be able to make your
keep your commit history basically keep
everything the way it should be
the reason and correct me if I'm wrong
the reason that this actually worked was
because that there was no difference
really there were there weren't any new
commits on the master branch that would
have made it a lot more complicated so
and like I said I'm not like super
expert at this because I don't often get
pool requests so correct me if I'm
mistaken that but this this only worked
out I think because of that it was
simple so if you had kind of a more
complicated situation do this or do the
rebase like like Thor and I Andrew and a
few other people in the live chat we're
suggesting so I'm gonna go to a live
chat because I did ask some questions
about what I was doing and I want to get
I want to read out the answers to you
[Music]
andrew did have a link he did share a
link of an article for how to do rebase
but there's i'm not going to read it out
because it has a lot of numbers and
letters at the end so andrew if you want
to put that in the comments for the
video so people watching later on the
recording can can go there as well that
would be awesome and it's going to get
blocked by the spam filter but i'll go
in and approve it later on
um Thor says get merged and then with
the flag squash would have been a better
option I'm not familiar with that flag
so anybody familiar with the flag squash
let me know what what that would do I
know that I I read it I remember seeing
that in the documentation but I don't I
don't pay enough attention to it that I
actually remember what it does the floor
says normally you don't want all these
small commits Andrew says it depends on
if you want to keep commit history all
right in this case if I would have done
the books this command and this is this
is basically Thor and Andrea are giving
a lot of helpful a lot of helpful
information here so I'm just kind of
relaying this to you all Andrew says if
we would have done this command it would
have created an unnecessary merge
message okay so basically this would
have forced a merge message so I would
have had to have and I a few times it's
happened that I've had to do a merge
message on the live stream basically it
would have forced me to type a message
explaining what's happening like why are
you it would ask me why are you why is
this merge necessary now to explain that
so sometimes you want that but Andrew
says like in this case unnecessary right
there are no conflicts we don't you know
it all just works Thor says squash would
have squash all the commits from the
feature branch into one so would have
just been one commit instead of all of
all of these commits that you see here
in the log
okay so it would have been Mike also
says squash would have made things
cleaner okay I could see the benefit of
that I actually because at least for me
because I'm not getting so many pull
requests I kind of like it like this and
this lets me see like exactly what was
done for me I like this because I'm
trying I really trying to learn from the
pool requests that you all submit so I
kind of like to be able to see all this
and be able to go through step by step
and see like what was changed why was it
change to help me understand it if that
wasn't if I didn't need to do that I
could definitely see the benefit of
using the squash flag and just making it
one down into one but for me at least at
this point I like this right now so but
this could definitely get really messy
if you're pulling in a lot of different
stuff so anyway that's some a lot of
good info about get merges and how to do
things and I'm glad we did this because
I to be honest with you there were so
many options when I was checking I
always look this up because I don't do
it often enough that I remember how to
do it and every time I look it up I
always see so many different ways that
people do it you know Stack Overflow as
you know different ways people were
doing it even you know there are a lot
of ways to do it and I'm not always
clear of what the benefit of doing it
one way or another is so so this is this
has been really helpful for me and
hopefully for you all and anybody
watching this later on if you're not
sure how to get out of this blog when
you do it just hit Q so may be able to
save you a few few minutes of
frustration just take you and it'll get
you out
okay so MK tech says you do need to be
careful with squash if you are working
in a group okay good yeah so yeah in
this case yeah no not in this case would
it matter so much but okay so now that
we've made this merge like let's just
look at it right I mean you we do want
to double check and make sure that
everything we did is working let me see
where I I pulled this over here we go
let me pull this back over and we can
see I'm gonna do a refresh just to just
to double check we do have the hot
module reloading going on so it should
reload but just in case so we can see
like okay we have this which we knew you
know right off the bat this is this is
different okay so we are on master now
okay before we only saw this on the
feature branch so that's a good
indication because most of the changes I
think all of the changes were all kind
of behind the scenes this is really the
only change that had any effect on what
the user would see so this is a good
visually the only visual indicator we
have that the change is really there I
mean obviously we know we know it works
we saw it here but just you know just
for the for the visual proof
confirmation here so and I'm just going
to click around I'm going to open up dev
tools like I already did this on the on
the other branch beforehand so I mean
I'm pretty confident that everything's
gonna be alright and it's all going to
work out but just for the sake of
demonstration I'll click around just so
we can see
see what's going on here all right and
everything seems to be working this this
violation here this is because of this
video so I don't know if I can do
anything about that so you can see this
is the the code for this YouTube embed
so if anybody knows how to do anything
about that let me know as far as I know
I'm pretty much stuck with this but
maybe there's a way to use video in here
so that that I just don't know about
just trying to click around making sure
this works awesome alright and that's
that's pretty much it so we made kind of
a major I can also show you the code
this would be the last test and now we
have the right version of next let's go
into like one of our pages so if you can
look up here we have layout everything's
in layout we've gotten rid of all that
that head stuff that we had before we
have our new folder on the side I know
this is small here on the side I don't
really know how to make this stuff
bigger but we have our new utils folder
we have some more in components we have
some extra components here that we
didn't have before so yeah so
everything's in there everything's
working reading no error messages so
successfully I don't think I had a
trailer thing so I have nothing to move
over and done because I didn't even make
that a task but yeah so everything
worked out and we're on track to have an
episode that is less than one hour which
was was the goal that we established
last week and we couldn't quite achieve
that goal house so awesome that we did
it this week so good way to start the
week here as always i'm going to do some
question and answer right now so want to
keep it kind of short so like five
minutes you know ten minutes max so i
can get over to my meeting at 3:00 also
just want to let you know if you're
following along with the with the
project you can see like pretty much
nothing has gotten done since Friday so
sorry but sorry about that
today was filled with like meetings and
just answering emails I don't know how
it is free for you all where you work
but it seems like Monday morning is just
crazy for email you know you get you got
all these emails built up people sending
stuff on the weekend and it just took me
forever to get through them all someone
really really important though and then
I had a meeting before this so actually
going to have I think two student
workers this summer that are going to
work remotely for me on some of these
sites so that's going to be that's gonna
be pretty exciting I thank you to be
good they're computer science students
here so hopefully they'll get some good
experience to be able to put some stuff
on the resume and github profile alright
so now I'm going to take a look at the
live chat if you have a question go
ahead and throw it out there now or put
it in the comments for the video or you
can direct message me on Twitter
let's see
oh good good looks about so Sebastian I
forgotten to do this and I what was it
already up-to-date good wait a second
hey I'm sorry Sebastian said install the
last update of NEX now that you've
updated your package.json so yeah that's
really weird I should have
if anybody knows what's going on with
this let me know but I should have had
to have reinstalled to the next version
of next here so that changed so what
should have happened is when I typed in
your niche it should have installed the
new updates some a little bit confused
by that I don't know if there's a way if
I could go into maybe like the node
modules to verify what the version is
my okay see like a fine next alright so
next is in here
I'm trying to find somewhere where it
give me a version number
yeah version two point four point three
okay so yeah so this is in fact two
point four point three so I don't know
what happened or why that worked but it
works
but anyway Sebastian good thought I mean
after you said that I immediately
thought like yeah I do need to do that
so for some reason I didn't need to do
that but anyway whenever you are doing
like a game pool or emerge or anything
like that it is a good idea to just type
in like npm install or yarn if you're
using yarn just to make sure I don't
know how many times it's happened to me
that I forgot to do that and I'm getting
weird errors and I wasted a lot of time
trying to figure out the error when the
problem was just that I didn't pull in
the package usually it's not necessarily
an update but like I've actually added a
package somewhere on another computer
and then just forgotten so anyway good
good thought the Sebastian Vinay
I assume that's how you pronounce your
name let me know if it's not and I will
correct myself so Vinay asks why are you
not using any linter um basically I just
didn't I haven't taken the time to
install a linter and use it so I know I
think I explained some of this before
but there are things that I probably
should be doing that I just never did
for two reasons one I work by myself so
I usually don't have to worry about can
my teammates read this so I've let
myself get a little bit sloppy at times
in terms of my style my coding style my
documentation like things like that or
even just like testing it in terms of
like an actual like test suite like
using like mocha or chai or something
like that also like the second reason
just
the busyness in the pace of the projects
here is just sometimes it stops me from
learning things and in doing things that
I know I should be doing because it's
hard to explain to other people like the
people above me that don't really know
the importance of those things why I
should push the date back of something
because I need to set this stuff up
because so anyway
Vinay what would you recommend for a
linter that I should use because if you
have recommendation I'm I definitely
want to try it out part of the reason -
I don't implement stuff like that
sometimes it's just I'm not sure which
one to go with and I'm just like instead
of just trying one I just research and
research and never make the decision one
way or another Andrew says I have an
exciting app idea to create project
folder and project wait what
alright I'm not sure Andrea I'm not sure
with that comment about I have an
exciting app idea create project folder
I'm not sure what that was in reference
to so let me know I'm missing something
I think I'm missing some joke here
obviously but Andrew says you're the new
update was installed when I typed yarn
in the feature branch that's what I
obviously I thought that in the feature
branch but because node modules is get
ignored I wasn't sure if it would
transfer over so that's why I thought I
would have to do it again evidently it
did transfer over and so I guess that's
why it works
okay so we have a suggestion to use es
lint and to use a plugin for the text
editor okay yeah I'll try that and would
be prefer a preferred Vanessa's prefer a
pool request with linter and prettier
setup okay
yeah and Andrew says it was a joke I got
that it was a joke I just didn't get the
joke exactly and I wasn't sure what like
what prompted like if I had missed some
conversation earlier that that joke was
in response to but in case you're all
watching this is what I was talking
about Andrew says one have an exciting
app idea to create project folder three
include web pack 47 so step four teas
have lose all passion for project and is
it supposed to be four or forty seven
unless they're anyway lose our passion
for project and give up go to one all
right I get it now the thing that threw
me is for some reason I thought it said
I have an exciting app idea so I was
expecting the next thing to be your idea
I
but it didn't say that it's it just said
have an exciting app idea so sorry about
that
it was nothing wrong with with what how
and rephrase that or anything it was
entirely my miss reading of that that
ruined it for me
so yeah the the joke is about how
difficult web pack is which is why I
like to use next j/s because I don't
have to worry about web pack and it kind
of handles all that stuff for me
okay so Vinay says I use standard Jas
and next Jas also uses it but if you
prefer semicolons then we can use EXO or
yes Lynn actually I don't prefer
semicolons it's been like so ingrained
in me that you're supposed to use
semicolons like I mean I don't know if
it's just
experience but for most other things in
JavaScript it was always like use a
semicolon you know like oh when I was
first learning JavaScript everything
said use the semicolon so now I catch my
if I really think about it I don't use
them but if I'm just kind of not
thinking and I'm typing away and I
always put in the semicolons so then a I
think I'll go with standard J s because
it will probably be good for me and help
me to quit using semicolons when I don't
need to oops and it is almost 3 o'clock
so like if you have any other questions
just put them up on Twitter or in the
comments to this video thank you for all
the help and hopefully you know someone
out there had you know had a good
educational experience from this and
Vinay thanks again for this amazing pool
request I really appreciate it and I'll
see you all tomorrow same time 2:00 p.m.
Eastern